I've got Heather on the line Heather how
are you I'm fantastic how are you oh I'm
focused and not finished how can I help
you today
I'm calling because my husband and I use
the every dollar budget and found that
we here every month
$80 under and he's been out of work for
about eight months and we decided that
with my company I'm pretty steady so we
got one loan to start a business for him
which hasn't taken off yet
of course because it's new and then the
other thing was that we took a
consolidation loan and when I found out
that the interest rate was at 34% I kind
of dated and then called my 401k again
and I said how can I help how can I get
help and I said well tickle them pick
your second loan for me a 401k pay off
the debt consolidation loan it's only a
5% loan through the 401k and then take
extra money so that you aren't in the
red when you you know while you're
waiting for your husband okay but that
put us at $80 short every month and I'm
feel like I've cancelled all a council
table the only thing I haven't cancelled
here there's our cell phones and um you
know about ready to do that too but you
know it's scary there's so much to do
that I just respect well you got a you
got a lot going on Heather and the first
thing I want you to know is that I hear
you okay I hear you and this is a
frustrating time for several reasons
you've got some stress you got things
happening how much debt do you guys oh
right now all total 43,000 okay in that
43,000 is that credit card student loans
student loans in the 401k loans okay and
how big is the 401k loan it was two of
them together at 30 okay so that total
of 30,000 and then student loans at 30
okay let's go back to another thing you
said your husband's been out of work for
eight months yes why um he just he was
trying to get back into the flooring
business that he was doing and it just
wasn't picking up for him and he's a
really good chef so we thought hey let's
you know let's do a catering business so
we started we bought all the supplies
with that first 401k loan and it just
you know it takes time to build a
business which I understand but in the
meantime we need to feed our kids we got
two kids you have two kids
what's the household income what's your
income right now my income net is about
fifty nine okay all right well here's
the reality you got a couple things
going on you guys you got you got a
budgeting type situation more
importantly though you got an appetite
for debt you can't borrow your way out
of this stuff and that's what you've
been doing you've been stealing from
your future taken from the 401k to try
to clean up the mess now and all its
doing is compounding your husband in the
idea of trying to start a business
I love entrepreneurs I love business I
love people starting businesses but
here's the deal right now you guys have
to feed a family you have to take care
of business so he needs to go get a job
okay not the job I know he's preferring
to be in the flooring industry but he
needs income coming in as a man that
will change his spirit and his psyche to
be able to have money coming in then he
can start to work on the catering
business on the side so no more
purchasing of equipment for the catering
business you could buy all kinds of
things and until you all are reaching
out you've got a need in the market or
you've got people that you can serve
what you have is a bunch of equipment
that's sitting there for a large family
cookout okay and that's not what you're
looking for and so I want you to
encourage him sit down let's look at
this how do we get some money coming in
here and then the catering businesses
the thing on the side that's the thing
you're looking at how do we go about
this and how do you approach it so I
would encourage you as you're looking at
your budget you guys are probably still
eating out and doing some other things
the $80 you can you can fix that
but the mindset is as more money needs
to come in and that's the reality and
hopefully you can sit down with him and
you guys can talk about that and yes he
can still look to get into the flooring
industry and the catering thing but he
needs a daytime job right now and that's
the reality and I need you to talk with
him about it and care enough to tell him
that so you can get some of this stress
and pressure off of you right now you're
shouldering at all and this is not the
time to try to start a business you got
to feed your family then you look how do
we do this on the side and be able to
grow it and I've got several friends
that are in the catering industry and it
is busy and it's tough and it's feast or
famine and so it's the mindset of
where's business coming from where are
the opportunities and so have that
conversation you won't look at it you
need to gain agreement on what's being
spent no eating out I mean you're gonna
have some creative meals trust me lima
beans and ramen noodles and all this
other stuff but we gotta get down to
bare basics and we talk about that as
the four walls your housing your
transportation clothing right housing
transportation clothing and then food
and so food doesn't mean eating out and
I promise you if you guys will tighten
down that's important and these 401k
loans concern me Heather for the simple
fact of if you were to lose or leave
that job those can become due and
payable very quickly typically within
sixty to ninety days so that thing needs
to get attacked and so you can give to
yourself a raise because that's the best
way to give yourself a raise is to get
yourself out of debt that's the truth
I'm telling you